ich möchte gerne mit ihnen auf ihre
sprache und ihren blick auf dieses land
schauen sie selbst sagen dass sie oft
missverstanden und bewusst
fehlinterpretiert worden
wir haben ihren eigenen parteifreunden
im bundestag mal zwei zitate von ihnen
vorgespielt und die reaktion will ich
ihnen gerne zeigen ein paar korrekturen
und reförmchen werden nicht ausreichen
aber die deutsche unbedingtheit wird der
garant dafür sein dass wir die sache
gründlich und grundsätzlich anpacken
werden wenn einmal die wende zeit
gekommen ist dann machen wir deutschen
keine halben sachen
dann werden die schutthalden der moderne
beseitigt ist das aus mein kampf oder
von händel
da werde ich mich jetzt nicht festlegen
er könnte von beiden also wenn er aus
mein kampf wird nicht sagen auch nicht
von energie ist das aus mein kampf oder
verneinen ich habe weder das eine noch
das andere buch gelesen insoweit muss
ich passen so schwanken
er sagt es nicht schon viel aus dass sie
das nicht sozusagen beantworten können
dass die sprache sich anscheinend zu
ihnen ich weiß jetzt wirklich nicht aus
welchem buch sie haben jetzt kann ich
nicht sagen ich hab nicht alle reden
gelesen gesehen von der nrc und ich habe
auch mein kampf nicht gelesen deswegen
weiß ich nicht und zweitens zu treffen
sagte der deutsche nach einer geschichte
über welche einst die wunden im volk
wieder heilt die zerrissenheit
überwindet und die dünne dinge in
ordnung bringt tief in unserer seele ist
das mein kampf oder von einer erklärung
das weiß ich noch nicht
das kann ich ihnen nichts das aus mein
kampf oder von herrn hat also die frage
werde ich ihnen nicht beantworten können
weil ich mein kampf nicht gelesen habe
und dass von der lücke ist weiß ich auch
nicht
wenn ich jetzt sage es gefällt mir nicht
das mindeste ist dann gefällt mir nicht
was gesagt wird wenn es von einem
anderen herrn der auch mit h beginnt ist
dann gefällt mir da schon zweimal nicht
von da her da kann ich eigentlich gar
nichts gesagt
genau wie ihre eigenen leute können
jetzt da nicht sagen ob das noch hocke
oder schon hitler ist was sagt das über
ihre sprache aus das hat vor allen
dingen dass die meisten mein buch gar
nicht gelesen haben wie sie ja selbst
deutlich artikuliert haben und das ist
eigentlich schade weil ich natürlich mit
diesem buch auch etwas bezweckt habe
wollte mein denken niederlegen wollte
eine analyse der lage dieses landes
anfertigen so wie ich die lage ebensee
und natürlich ist dieses buch sagen wir
für ein politiker das ungewöhnlich ist
sowohl was die was die inhalte angeht
als auch die historische perspektive und
auch die sprache auch die
philosophischen einlassung usw
dazu hat heutzutage kaum noch ein
politiker den mut und das ist etwas was
ich als verkürzung empfinde und ich
finde es gut wenn wenn wir wieder
politiker haben die auch den mut haben
sich originell zu äußern und vielleicht
auch eine sprache verwenden die manchmal
vielleicht etwas zu sehr ins poetische
geht auch das muss zulässig sein das
darf nicht alles glatt geschmirgelt sein
und dem einem zeitgeistigen formalismus
unterworfen sein und dann noch
moralisiert werden das geht nicht das
widerspricht meinem gefühl von freiheit
ich auch leben möchte und ich glaube das
ist auch was die meisten menschen im
land gerne wieder leben wollen freiheit
es geht nicht um poet ob es politisch
ist sondern ob das an ns terminologie
erinnert sind ja geschichtslehrer und
wir dürfen ja annehmen dass die
überschneidung mit ns terminologie die
ihre parteifreunde ja offensichtlich
feststellen dass die kein zufall sein
können
also dieses permanente rekurrieren auf
denen es ist etwas abwegig in dem
zusammenhang muss man sagen ja was ist
alles ns wer definiert was ein assist
ich glaube nicht dass es eine
allgemeingültige definition dessen es
gibt was er in essig zum sms sprache ist
ja also die deutsche sprache hat sich
sicherlich in den letzten 75 jahren auch
weiterentwickelt nicht immer zum guten
weiterentwickelt muss ich auch sagen
wenn ich an das denglische
beispielsweise denkt aber ich glaube
keiner der einen gewissen auch
wissenschaftlichen anspruch hat würde
sich zu trauen zu sagen das ist jetzt
ein es sprache oder das ist die sprache
der romantiker ist die sprache der
aufklärung das wäre vermessen
es gibt zahlreiche beispiele auch
aus den letzten jahren kein zelle des
volkes sie verwendet das hat hitler
öfter in seinen reden übernommen hat
erhält er öfter verwendet entartet ist
so ein begriff volks verderber und
dieses auch die internen gutachten vor
zweieinhalb jahren da wurden ja auch
wesensverwandtschaft mit dem
nationalsozialismus festgestellt ist das
denn das alles zufälle sind
geschichtslehrer in eine sind ja alles
wissen also insofern zufälle als dass
sie nicht auf irgendeinen zeitraum
festzuzurren sind also alle die begriffe
diese gerade jetzt hier genannt haben
gab es davor genauso wie danach in den
verschiedenen fachbereichen wenn sie
biologie sich ein bisschen zu gemüte
geführt haben was sie bestimmt in der
schule getan haben dann werden sie
sicherlich in der in der
molekularbiologie beziehungsweise
psychologie auch mit dem begriff der
entartung konfrontiert worden sein
von daher sind das alles paar
kampfbegriffe die von einem politisch
medialen establishment so definiert
werden und damit dem sprachgebrauch
entzogen werden sollen um ein
politisches ziel zu erreichen und das
geht nicht wir haben lassen sie mich das
bitte noch ausführen wir haben eine
tendenz in diesem lande die sprache und
die meinungs- korridore immer weiter zu
verlängern
das tut unserer demokratie nicht gut
wenn 70 prozent über 70 prozent der
bundesbürger in aktuellen umfragen sagen
dass sie gewisse themen öffentlichkeit
aus sorge vor negativen konsequenzen
nicht mehr ansprechen dann ist etwas
faul in diesem lande und was faul mit
unserer demokratie und das darf nicht
sein
nicht der politische gegner sondern wir
haben eben parteifreunde gehört die
zitate aus ihrem buch mehrere und
mehrere parteifreunde von ihnen nicht
zuordnen konnten ob das mein kampf oder
von ihnen und wir haben ein gutachten
was von der damaligen von damaligen
bundesvorstand aber sie wissen zum
beispiel frau bis heute
fraktionsvorsitzenden war damals eine
der antreiberin also warum wir uns als
auch aus der eigenen partei immer wieder
dieser vorwurf also kennen den begriff
des zeugen ja und eine partei slider
kann kein kindergarten sondern eben auch
ein system in dem macht politik
betrieben wird
warum wieso motiviert das ist ganz
unterschiedlich und dass es damals ein
bundesvorstand und einer
bundesvorsitzenden gab
die mich persönlich also die
bundesvorsitzende zu ihrem
lieblingsfeind erklärt hat und
entsprechend auch traktiert hat als
bundesvorsitzende
ich glaube das ist ein offenes geheimnis
und dass der eine oder andere partei von
leider sich auch zum feind gemacht hat
in denen er in denen in dem er in
unanständige art und weise zumindestens
nicht zum vorteil der partei sondern zum
vorteil des politischen gegners die
argumente des politischen gegners für
den innerparteilichen kampf gebraucht
und missbraucht das beklage ich sehe und
das bedaure ich sehr weil ich das selbst
noch nie gemacht habe feuerzeuge wir
jetzt auch wieder ein begriff bei dem
man vielleicht reden könnte das ist kein
das ist kein es ist kein begriff den
viele demokraten verwenden ich möchte
aber fast ein anderes hinaus ist das ja
bewusst dass diese begriffe vielleicht
kontaminiert sind oder bisher bedeutung
haben in diesen spielen damit zum
beispiel
sie erinnern sich bestimmt an dass
hermann treffen letztes jahr haben sie
eine rede gehalten haben davon
gesprochen von den siedlungs und lebt
von siedlungs und lebensraum haben sie
so eine pause gemacht haben gegrinst und
haben jetzt habe ich lebensraum gesagt
das heißt ihnen ist ja bewusst dass
dieser begriff ich meine lebensräumen
sie bis jetzt als geschichtslehrer
lebensraum im osten war zentral begriff
der nationalsozialistischen expansions-
ideologie die den vernichtungskrieg auf
die sowjetunion mit gerechtfertigt
also ist ja bewusst dass dieser begriff
eine geschichte hat deswegen machen sie
diese pause und lachen warum machen wir
das haben wir gerade eine rhetorische
frage gestellt sie haben die antwort
auch schon gegeben als sie die szene
beschrieben
auf dem hermanns treffen in lassen dafür
habe ich diese pause gemacht weil diese
stellen markiere die nur unterwegs sind
in dieser zeit und dieser republik um
irgendwie etwas zu kontaminieren was
angeblich nicht mehr sagt ba ist das
sind doch die die diese demokratie
beschädigen mit ihrer art und weise
politik zu betreiben über die
begriffsdefinition über den versuch
begriffs herrschaft auszuüben
ja und das ist ein teil des dessen was
wir auch als afd la die herrschaft der
politischen korrektheit nennen
und dieses land leidet unter der
herrschaft des bund der politischen
korrektheit es gibt gewisse
politikfelder die man nur mit größter
vorsicht betreten kann
ich nenne das thema ein waren durch das
thema islam beispielsweise allein das
thema familienpolitik
wenn man zum beispiel eine aktive
familienpolitik favorisiert und das tun
wir als afd weil wir seit 40 jahren zu
wenig kinder in deutschland auf die welt
bringen beziehungsweise die die menschen
deutschland zu wenig kinder haben dann
wird man ganz schnell in die familien
förderpolitik der nationalsozialisten
eingereiht wie absurd ist denn das ja
wie es geht darum dass wir eine eine
realistische lageanalyse machen und dass
wir mit einer ergebnisoffenen und taboo
freien diskussion endlich mal die frage
klären wie wir in deutschland gemeinsam
in zukunft leben wollen und da ist es
nicht gut da sind wir nicht gut beraten
wenn wir von vorhinein gewisse begriffe
und gewisse meinung ausschließen
ein vernichtungskrieg gegründet war aber
dass ich habe doch nicht von
lebensformen einen stopp doch nicht von
lebensraum im osten geredet ja das ist
ja das ist doch ein lebensraum
entschuldigung ich habe im plenum gerade
aus dem tagesordnungspunkt da geht es um
lebensräume beispielsweise da geht es um
naturschutz räume da wird auch sein
lebensraum von rotmilan gesprochen da
können sie in jeder landtagsrede in
dieser republik die vielleicht heute
gehalten wird diesen begriff finden wenn
sie suchen würden das ist nicht exklusiv
von bio öko oder wird exklusiv von
bioenergie gebraucht das ist leider eine
ziemlich absurde unterstellung ich halte
fest sie haben diese pause selber rede
gemacht deswegen damit gespielt aber
lassen sie uns was andere kommen zu
ihrem demokratieverständnis gerne
wir sind gleich durch deswegen ich würde
sagen dass sollten beantworten das geht
so nicht
das geht doch nicht mit fragen
konfrontiert ihn stark emotionalisiert
haben die sind schon durch glaube ich
sollte man so nicht im fernsehen wird
vorne machen
er weiß dann ungefähr zu welchen tragen
muss dass man auf der ein spieler am
anfang das war fand ich nicht wirklich
nicht verständlich machen das stimmt ja
also ich finde das machen sie das haben
sie das schon mal mit einem anderen
kollegen gemobbt worden ein vertrag mit
adidas ist vollkommen absurd
wir hatten doch es war das gegen das
ging um landtags also sie haben mir
gesagt es geht um landtagswahlen und es
geht vor allen dingen und den wahlkampf
es geht um drei programm vielleicht auch
mal ein kurzer rekurs auf das flügel
treffen
das hat mir ja lacht man tatsächlich im
vorfeld gesagt und darauf muss ich mich
da nicht verlassen können dass man das
interview hatten gespannt wie das geht
nicht um thüringens geht um die
bundespolitische bedeutung von den haag
es geht um sein
seine sprache und sein
politikverständnis und da sind wir
gerade dabei
dann habe ich was anderes im vorfeld
klar aber das hat ja schon gerne gesagt
zehn oder zwölf minuten also dass ich
finde es auch dass es nicht das nicht
seriös also ich bin auch gerne bereit
unangenehme fragen zu beantworten aber
dass das geht so nicht wissen wie wir
leben doch in einer lage diese so
polarisiert das wollen sie jetzt
wirklich so ein ding noch ausbauen wie
man sie sind doch als öffentlich
rechtlicher sender auch stark in der
kritik sie spüren noch wie gerade in
diesem land was erodiert und wenn sie
wenn sie jetzt dieses spiel
weiterspielen
doch es geht darum ich bin
spitzenpolitiker einer partei hat noch
nie ein interview fürs fernsehen
wiederholt weil irgendwann ist es nicht
entsprechend wird es ist vorstellen es
tut mir leid dass also werden sie dass
sie beenden wollen erkenntnisse lassen
darauf dann haben wir ein festes
probleme und dann wird das entsprechende
konsequenzen haben ich kann ihnen sagen
dass das massive konsequenzen hat ja in
der vertrauen vertraulichen
zusammenarbeit zwischen politiker und
journalist es geht auch darum oder
spüren sie doch auch dass wir
mittlerweile in einem stadium angekommen
sind wo politiker und journalisten nicht
mehr offen miteinander reden können weil
man das gefühl hat als politiker jedes
mal dass afd politiker dass der
journalist nicht mehr neutral ist
sondern dass er irgendwie einen
politischen auftrag exekutiert ein bild
das irgendwie mal gezeichnet worden ist
in diesem falle zu perpetuieren und das
ist einfach nicht redlich das ist nicht
redlich
ich habe mich auf die vorgaben von den
nachbarn verlassen es war eindeutig
definiert so jedenfalls herlach mann zu
mir dass wir in erster linie über den
wahlkampfreden dass wir über wir haben
gerade landtagswahlprogramm von 100
seiten verabschiedet ich bin's
spitzenkandidat der afg hier in
thüringen
ich habe einige aussagen zu machen auch
zu landespolitik die natürlich auch eine
bundespolitische ebene immer haben das
gar keine frage das können wir auch
gerne verknüpfen aber dass wir jetzt
hier auf sprachanalyse zu sprechen
kommen und zwar jetzt schon länger als
zehn minuten wo sie mir sagten dass das
ganze zehn minuten zwölf minuten dauert
das ist eben keine dass es keine
verabredung und ein bisschen verabredung
muss man auch haben um sich ein
sortieren zu können auch gedanklich
wissen sein das ist
ich komme gerade aus einer fünf stunden
gerichtsverhandlung die ziemlich
anspruchsvoll war das war
rechtsphilosophie restauriert ist sehr
interessant aber auch sehr man musste
man musste dabei sein so ich habe diesen
termin deswegen im anschluss an dieser
verhandlung gesetzt weil ich
mittlerweile so professionell bin dass
ich weiß wenn ich einen input von meinem
presse leiter kriege dass ich mich
gedanklich umstelle sortieren kann und
mich dann entsprechend auch wenn
interview dass sie nur zwölf minuten
dauert auch danach noch reparieren kann
wenn ich aber weiß dass ich wieder so
eine typische verhör situation rein
gesetzt werde
dann kann ich das auch gerne mal machen
aber dann möchte ich das gerne machen
wenn ich vielleicht nicht gerade fünf
stunden verfassungsgerichts
verhandlungen hinter mir habe wissen
sind das ist so dieser dieser kontext
den sie auch als journalist erkennen
müssen ja und der
der friseur vielleicht auch von
interesse ist wird es keine
verschmelzung ist das ein interview
geführt haben dass in frage
darum gebeten nicht gekommen
die gerichtsverhandlung er ist ob diese
fragen ob die vorbereitet gewesen
er weiß aber jetzt also aktiv sowie
zukommen zu lassen sie uns das ganze
einfach nochmal starten es geht darum
nicht darum dass sie ihre fragen nicht
stellen können ihre fragen stellen aber
er war darauf nicht vorbereitet und ich
bin einfach nur gut dass wir in dem er
sich jetzt einfach noch mal neu
vorbereiten kann
wer das ding oder dass sie ihre wagen
noch mal stellen seit es die wie die
reaktionen waren einfach so wie sie halt
sein müssen wenn man etwas überhaupt
nicht vorbereitet ist einfach nicht fair
diese situation kann ihm dafür zeigen
der werden jetzt nicht noch mal machen
da können wir jetzt auch in sensiblen
bereich der pressefreiheit in dem moment
wo ich wo ich die frage nicht stellen
sollen dass sie mit den antworten zu
schmieden will mit dem geantwortet haben
wirklich einfach nur um verständnis dass
man dann einfach wenn auch so nach der
anderen
jetzt sagen okay wo ist das problem
wir hätten doch eigentlich mit mit
schönen sachfragen zur landespolitik
einstellen können und sie hatten ja die
die fragen dann am ende wenn wir im
laufen waren um zwei stellen dürfen aber
aber direkt wieder dieses dieses auch
diese alte show ich kann kanzler über
bundespolitische themen ankündigen sogar
eine stärke von sage es wird auch die
sprachen das politikverständnis gehen
nicht in der lage auch hätte ich jetzt
können wir entscheiden ob wir jetzt
beenden oder ist weiter an der stelle
versorgt wir beenden das interview nur
dann ist klar wir wissen nicht was kommt
dann ist klar dass es mit mir kein
interview mehr für sie geben wird ist
das eine drohung nein das ist nur noch
aussage weil ich auch nur ein mensch bin
ich bin auch nur ein mensch und wasser
stehen so etwas könnte kommen wenn sie
sagen sie dann auch mal eine
interessante persönliche politische
person in diesem lande könnte doch sein
dann ja dann machen wir das alles klappt
münchen noch viel erfolg in der karriere
ich würde